[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
my god
[Music]
lovers
[Music]
my
if
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my god
[Music]
will
my god
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
wd black fine-tuned for performance
purpose built for gamer to play without
limits
storage solutions with the capacity
speed
and reliability to win
wd black drive your game
[Music]
we awoke from one nightmare into another
not on our dying earth
but somewhere much worse
[Music]
we came to enoch as our last chance a
chance at a new home
but what we found didn't save humanity
it consumed it
[Music]
we awoke changed
the anomaly unleashed within us
burning's power impossible power
[Applause]
enoch robs us of our humanity yet gives
us so much more
each step taking us further from what we
were
and closer to what we must become
the riverbed
[Music]
uh
oh
what's up everybody and welcome to
outriders revealed
today we are going to blow the lid off
of square enix and people can fly's
third person shooter
and go in depth and talk about
everything that this game
has to offer i go by the name of malik
forte and i am so
grateful to be joined today by people
can fly game director
bartek comita and lead writer joshua
rubin
how's it going guys so happy to see you
so i hope you guys can join me today
good to see you ready to talk about this
game uh first off though i got to ask
you guys how does it feel to finally be
able to tell everybody about this tell
the world about what you've been working
on
oh it's amazing yeah it's our first game
since we left epic games
so it's really big moment for us so we
are super excited that we can share
all about the game with the world yeah
it's crazy it has been a while since
we've seen a game from people can find
you guys are primarily known for your
shooters
uh so uh tell me what is it that
constitutes a good shooter game
in your opinion in my opinion the good
shooter is
made from many elements like enemy
behavior
level layout pacing but i think the most
important part is when you
press the trigger and you feel this
almost tangible
feel of the gun this impact it has
that's what makes the great shooter
we've already seen the first trailer
that's out uh and it's been revealed so
we kind of have a little bit of an idea
of the story and what to uh what to
expect with outrider but i'd like to
know
from your mouth bartek the director's
pitch for outriders so
sum it up for us sure it's one two three
player
co-op shooter with brutal powers deep
rpg mechanics and strong story and while
we're on the subject
of story that's why we got you here
joshua you've got quite
some credentials on you you are co-wrote
assassin's creed 2
you worked on destiny game of thrones
walking dead
with telltale games so you're all about
big story and big characters how was it
bringing that here
into this game that's amazing i mean
it's amazing working on
great ips but to get to invent an ip to
get to build a whole new sci-fi world
from a blank canvas
i mean you know for creatives like us
and our team i mean that's that's a
dream job
uh we you know basically started from
zero
we created a hundred years of lore
you know going back to like you know all
of the seismic conflict that
destroyed our planet the colonization of
a new planet working with these
incredible scientists to know how that
would really happen
to how it would then go disastrously
wrong
because i mean you've seen the trailer
you've played the game now you know this
is a
dark game i mean and that was really
important to us in building the shooter
that we wanted to build a game
that was not clean sci-fi right this is
this is
a brutal nightmarish world that you're
going into yeah you're not lying about
that and i've consumed quite a bit of
sci-fi
in my time from games to movies and
stuff this one takes the cake as being
one of those darker
stories but you know what i feel like
right now everyone else i want to get
them in the same
frame of mind so we're going to show a
little bit more here we got a nice video
for you guys to check out this right
here
is world and story check it out
we came to enoch looking for hope
a fresh start on an untouched planet
then we found the signal so we set out
to discover its source
that was our first encounter with the
anomaly
when the storm struck the outriders were
forced back into cryosleep
while we slept the anomaly raged
and the creatures of enoch advanced
thirty years later when we finally woke
the world had changed
but so had we
with our advanced technology rendered
useless by the anomaly
a successful colonization wasn't
possible
but after all these years the signal is
still out there
and at its source a chance to find
answers
to start again
[Music]
okay all right so there was a whole lot
to digest there in that trailer
so all right let me recollect a little
bit wait a second let me recollect so
humanity leaves earth
then the outriders go to enoch under the
new planet enoch they're the first to
land there
and then they discover a mysterious
signal and then everything goes to hell
am i right about that josh
yeah yeah i mean exactly you can sort of
imagine that you know this is the last
gasp of humanity earth is
gone and these half a million refugees
are on this arc ship to this lush green
new planet it's a second chance
for humanity and the outriders are
like the vanguard of this crew
they're the first ones to land on the
planet first boots on the ground they're
the ones
who are going to be the mercenaries and
explorers that kind of begin
this colonization process but
then they get their first taste of the
anomaly
and yeah everything goes to [ __ ] really
okay i'm interested to know more about
the
anomaly but first i need to ask you
what's the signal because there was a
big
you know point in that trailer there's a
big plot point so
what is the importance of the signal can
you guys tell me this thing we cannot
tell
because because it's one of the biggest
mystery of this planet
but it's important that the reason for a
player to start a journey
okay so it's the motive for the players
to figure out what that signal is and uh
what's the anomaly what is that i i can
tell you this
you first see it as as you did in the
trailer as the storm
that kind of throws everything we know
about physics
upside down time gravity um
when you you know if you get hit by the
storm
most people it just tears apart but some
people
get rebuilt they come back as gods
and this is what happens to you to your
outright or when you wake up
30 years later the the you discover that
the flora and fauna of this planet has
been hyper evolved these little critters
that were really cute at the beginning
are
not so cute anymore and you your whole
dna
has been rebuilt and you are now what
they call an enoch
the altered wow all right so the anomaly
is essentially what's giving everyone
their powers
right that's right okay and i also saw
in that trailer there were a couple more
humans that
looked like they had some abilities as
well some some powers
per se uh is it safe to call them
altered as well
are they villains are they bad guys like
who are they they are altered
that's okay to call them but not
villains we are trying to avoid
overall using villains and heroes good
guy and bad guys
overall we try to make universe when
everything is quite
colours of gray yeah morally everyone is
morally questionable from you
to the people you're fighting yes right
and really the whole world
is trying to exactly and the same with
others you will be during your journey
some of them will be maybe against you
some of them maybe will help you
right so it's not really just that cut
and dry well if it's good or bad
everything's kind of just basically
subjective toward the player that's
pretty cool
all right so i want to talk a little bit
more about what we saw in that trailer
as far as the outriders that we saw
is that who i'm going to be playing as
um
you can but you can also create your own
outrider because we have a customization
options so you can
choose if you want to be a female man if
you want to
choose a what kind of hair you want to
wear what kind of markings
scars so it's up to you what you want to
play i play with a mohawk and a
big-ass beard that seems like
i would imagine that's kind of like how
you feel inside like if i could grow a
mohawk again i promise
so it's cool it's cool that you uh you
don't have to play as the outriders you
saw in that trailer i think that's
really important for everyone to know
you can create your own character that's
amazing
but we have these incredible actors
playing both the male and female
versions of the main character so you
get
really your own unique version of
outriders when you play
that's really cool that's really cool um
so when you create your outrider and
you're out there
and you're playing co-op with your
friends how does that work
and how does it work when you're trying
to tell a story but you have three
people all playing in the same game
it's really cool actually because we've
got about 90 minutes of cutscenes
and about two hours of additional side
quest cut scenes
and it's epic and in every one of those
cut scenes
you your character with all of your gear
and customization you are the star of
that scene
but your buddies are in the scene with
you
in the background with their gear and
your gearing customization
and what's really cool is that when they
see the same cut scene at the same time
as you do
they're the star of the scene and you're
in the background with all your gear and
customization
okay that's cool that's cool everybody
gets to represent or be represented
in their friends game as well as their
own and i think that's cool you get to
be the star of your own game but the
supporting star and everyone else's at
the same time at the same time that's
really cool
uh i want to know a little bit more
about the story because i feel like the
trailer gave us a good taste
for the grim and the dark environment
and atmosphere that you're getting ready
to enter but where does it go beyond
that does it get darker
[Music]
i would say it's kind of a classic
journey to the heart of darkness it's
got
like a real 1970s apocalypse now vibe
and you as you go in search of the
signal
you are leading this caravan through
this war-torn
wasteland and you go all the way to the
very edge of civilization
and beyond um there's a whole world
out there to explore and it's filled
with
history and mysteries that we are only
just beginning to touch on in this first
game
speaking of which is there any more you
can tell us about enoch because i feel
like
we kind of got a taste for how dark it
can be and how lush it can be at the
very same time is there any more
you can expound upon i think overall i
think that you know he's one of the
protagonists of this game yeah room is
like a character yeah
really yes so it has so many mistress
and so many secrets you will
have to discover that big too i know
that's what i really love
that you know it goes from like the mud
and the grit
of you know what feels like you know
like like almost a world war one
on an alien planet just the beginning i
guess yeah but then beyond that you go
you go
past the edge and
there are forests and there are
mountains and there are
deserts and each of these places is
bigger than the last and it's not an
open world
i think that's important to say but
it's more of a like a hub and spoke
structure so you go with your caravan
and when you land in these places
that becomes your core and then you move
out from there in every
direction getting to explore and find
more and more
right very cool very cool i like that i
like that because you guys are using
these rpg elements to tell this story
and the story appears to be vast so i
can't wait to jump in
and it's just so intriguing to hear what
you guys have to say about it but
while we're on the subject of rpg
elements i think uh it would be
cool right now to dive a little bit
deeper into what those
exactly are so why don't we go ahead and
take a look at the rpg elements
in outriders
as we venture across enoch we discover a
violent new world
while we slept those that survived the
anomaly did what they could to carve out
a living
and something resembling society took
shape
we scavenge for weapons and armor and
trade what little resources we have in
order to give ourselves a fighting
chance of survival
we engineer vehicles from scrap and set
out towards the horizon
and as we push farther into the unknown
our powers grow alongside our knowledge
of how to use them
but as we start to understand our power
we discover there are others
who have paid a heavier price
oh man guys there's a whole lot of fun
happening in that right there
so much stuff to talk about but uh i
want to break down some of the rpg
elements that i'm seeing here because
this looks like a lot man uh do you
think people
are going to be surprised with how
robust the rpg elements and outriders
are
i think they will be because on one hand
we double down our expertise with
shooters
but then we add a lot of elements that
are more common with action rpg games
not with the shooters okay so you say
common uh what are some other
traditional
rpg elements that you guys added into
outriders
okay so i think in our game the most
common traditional elements are the side
quests the skill tree
the classes the of course the loot
and the rarity of it right now all of
you liking the rpg games we
have in our game right right and lots of
customization it looks like as well too
oh yeah everything can be customized
right well one thing i i noticed
you were guys were customizing an
outrider's truck
in that trailer too well tell me about
that what is this outrider's truck and
what can i do with it
outright truck is basically your home so
when you are moving somewhere you are
taking your truck with you
and your friends that will join this
track and your journey but the funny
thing is when you
join your other colleague to play
multiplayer multiplayer game
then you create the convoy of trucks
important to say probably that you can't
drive the trucks
by the way the trucks are kind of your
home you have your own driver so yeah
yeah exactly yeah well i'm an outrider i
don't need you i i have my own driver i
don't need to be doing the driving i got
fighting to do
exactly you can customize of course and
once more you can
add some trophies to this track to show
off what you have done in the game how
is your progress going
so if you kill a big-ass monster you can
put his head right on the front of your
truck
yeah so that's cool it's really cool too
because like then
when you're with your friends like and
you're this convoy
when you come and you create a hub at a
place that you land you kind of create
almost like a circle
like a wagon circle yeah you know and
like all your your buddies are there and
also your characters are there your npc
core convoy characters are there and
they can do things like you know upgrade
your weapons and
you know um you know fix repair things
the new loot for you so a lot of you can
do side quests for them to more
familiarize with them you can chat
yeah you can actually sit around the
campfire and hear stories about old
earth
that's cool so a bit of a safe space for
you and your your buddies right
talk a little bit more about hub areas
because uh you you have that one with
your convoy but like are there
towns and cities where you can kind of
camp out too yeah they're these
settlements that you come across where
after the failed colonization of enoch
the survivors have kind of gathered in
these you know crags and riffs
of safety from the storms and the
endless war and kind of
eke out this survival civilization
it feels very gritty very real but
there's real lives going on there and
you can
get involved in these side quests you
know you can help people with their
stories people are not so nice
that you find and there's vendors right
that have these really unique items you
only get
in these specific locations so yeah and
each of these are
a hub as well that you could that you
find yourself in right i noticed when i
was playing actually too i i was in one
of the towns i think it was rift
city i believe i was in rift town rift
town yeah i was there
and i went up to the vendor and there
was some pretty nice uh gear there
in his shop though it was like almost i
wanted to buy it but i didn't have
enough scrap to get it
but since we're on the subject i want to
talk more about the gear
in this game because there's like a ton
of gear from what i saw how many weapons
are in this game
a lot there's so much so much yeah
because they're super super cool yeah
there's incredible artists cool looking
armor too like yeah
at the beginning you will start with the
something that we will have to scavenge
yeah but the more you
progress the more brutal the more crazy
the guns will become
yeah there's this amazing sense of like
the first guns that you're using really
are like you know like world war one
world war ii
really heavy ballistic artillery that
feel like you've you know built them
you know out of just crap that you found
right but as you go further into this
world and deeper and deeper
you get these really otherworldly
weapons i mean
there's this one that i don't know my
favorite is like this one
that's like this molten lava gun that's
like morphing in your hand as you're
blowing the [ __ ] out of people
it's really cool overall we wanted to
reflect the true items the world and
story
around us so we are smooth from the
lasers plastics and
yeah no lasers there are no lasers
[Music]
heavy yeah we're keeping the old school
here yeah that's good here
but the more the pro you progress the
more crazy stuff will pick up
right right well you can modify these
these things too right
the gear goes in the color coding with
when you're looting is it similar to
like other
so you know the more rare item the more
powerful it will be the color coding is
very
uh similar because we want to for the
elements that working good
we don't want to change them because
people will be not lost at the beginning
of the game right and
there's a common familiarity with that
between amongst gamers
so in the vein of customization and
enhancing my character i want to know a
little bit more about the skill trees
that i saw there could you tell us a
little bit more about that bartek
sure so when you level up your acquiring
points
you can spend on the skill tree and
through skill tree you are changing how
your character behaves on the
battleground
so you can become more powerful your
skills can be more important now than
guns or maybe you like guns more than
skills
or maybe you want to change your speed
or how you're behaving the cover so
all of this together through hold the
gameplay
will define how your end game build
works cool so i can like increase my
health you can use your health you can
extra damage
so it all synergize together
so you have to choose your own perfect
way through it that's cool
it's very important that each class has
his own separate
skill tree right so basically you can
differentiate your character
and make it according to your play style
you can just fine tune it
exactly awesome dude that's awesome
that's awesome and i imagine that works
really good
with what we're getting ready to talk
about next which is the classes
and the powers i guarantee you guys this
is the section you've been waiting for
we got a little video to show you first
and then we're going to deep dive into
this stuff
check it out many threats stem between
us
and the source of the signal
those of us who survived exposure to the
anomaly
moved beyond our physical limits
we've become altered
as pyromancers we manipulate explosive
volcanic energy and devastating walls of
flames
as tricksters we manipulate the fabric
of time and space
to take our enemies by surprise
and as devastators we shatter the earth
around us
a brute force powered by the planet
itself
and so our journey across enoch begins
to discover what lies at the heart of
the signal
all right everybody this is the part of
the show i'm pretty sure you've all been
waiting for
we're getting ready to break down these
classes you just saw the pyromancer the
devastator
and the trickster uh but to my knowledge
uh there's there's
one thing yes there's four classes yeah
right now we'll reveal only three of
them okay one will be secret okay so how
do these three classes work
trickster is assessing type time and
space
for everyone who likes a lot of movement
around the arena
for people who like to go behind the
enemies next one is pyromancer
a lot of damage but you like array of
effects
a lot of fire that's for you the last
one is devastator
guy for like to fight on the short range
guys who like to be tanky buffy maybe a
little bit reckless
but that's for guys who lead it and
personally that's for me yeah
for guys like me who just like to run
straight into the action without
consulting his teammates
that's me i love him no no i'm totally
the guy who like i'm time and space
right like i'm the trickster i like to
like all right so there's this really
cool thing you can do i'm sorry i'm just
going to take over where
where you like set your like teleport
exit right
and then you sneak up and you teleport
in right behind
all of the [ __ ] and you do this like
temporal slice thing that like freezes
their bodies
and then they become translucent you see
their skeletons like dissolve inside
and then just as the big [ __ ]
come at you boom you're out at your exit
point
it's so nice that's so cool that's so
cool i don't want to talk about this
anymore i want to see i don't know about
you guys but uh i'm ready to jump in
some gameplay yeah how's it sound all
right let's do it let's jump in
all right so paint the scene for me
where are we right here
this is the war zone when your outrider
first wakes up from cryosleep it's
right into this hellhole and you know
basically the idea is that
one of the aspects of the anomaly is
that it kills all electronics more
complicated than a light bulb
so humanity has been reduced to sort of
um pre-world war one technology so
that's
that's what this feels like it's like
trenches and tanks
but on an alien planet
um the enemies you're fighting these are
the insurgents
who are your you're the eca's at war
with
of course they don't call themselves
that they call themselves the exiles
and you know understanding the whole
tragic story behind this war
is a big part of the the mystery that
you're solving
right now we're looking at the trickster
am i correct in saying that yeah
the trickster so now we see the temporal
slice so first ability
you see that you are slowing everyone
and later killing them
right now this is slow trap so that's
really cool you are
you are fast but you can even slow down
dynamics which makes it even faster
that's cool the bullets going in slow
motion inside that bubble you're like
totally neo
yeah yeah but neo couldn't slow down the
jeep so if you explode somewhere
body parts we fly slow motion right
right i noticed that your health was low
how did you heal though
you're receiving some part of the health
through your assassination
the whole idea of doing damage is what
gives you your health back
wow oh and this right here is the
devastator correct yes that's your
favorite class yes the
reckless guy right here this is who i'm
gonna play here we are healing when you
are close to the enemies and we are
killing them so the more enemies around
you
the better and the skill we are seeing
is the earthquake so basically like a
better shotgun okay so you can synergize
it together and kill a lot of enemies
in the close close combat oh the next
skill we see right now
is the basically armor it's the golem oh
that's changing into the
almost indestructible guys so you can
even be more close and more tanky and
more buffed
that's exactly what i need yeah i need
to be more tanky oh yeah i like it i
like how his skin is like
rock solid and everything or his or her
depending on which way you decide to go
in customization
this is one of the hub errors you were
talking about earlier if i'm not
mistaken is this uh
rift town reef town yes it's a reef town
yeah this is one of the
first large hubs in the game you come to
you know basically like after the
anomaly storms have
destroyed the first city and the
monsters have started coming and the
insurgency
has started rising those who are loyal
to the eca have retreated into this rift
for protection
this is like one of the first places on
enoch where a kind of civilization has
survived
it is a harsh broken world yeah that you
find in this place
but it's also the first time in the game
that you really get to slow down
yeah and start to kind of explore and
start to kind of unravel some of the
mysteries that are a key part of this
game
yeah it feels desolate but hopeful at
the very same time
so how does the loot system work i'm
noticing there's vendors can i buy
and sell things with the vendors like
gear or whatever
yes so overall you are finding a lot of
stuff in the world
you can scrap you can destroy so you can
receive money for it so
our money is called scrap basically okay
and then if you have
bad luck let's say in the world finding
the cool load you can buy it through the
vendors or maybe you are missing some
item that you want
or maybe there will be some more do you
want to purchase
you can do this through scrap all right
all about that scrap keep it in your
pocket
how do i move from one environment and
get to the next
so the story's carrying you forward and
the journey is really important and
every time you kind of move you open up
a whole new area
adjacent to your hub and once you've
captured an area
so to speak you can fast travel in
between them oh is that what that flag
is yes got it okay that makes sense
where are we here so this is the first
city
that i mentioned earlier okay which is
now totally in ruins
yeah this is a city i don't see a city
it was supposed to be this was sort of
like like the place that the
colonization started
right um that huge thing that we saw on
the horizon like dominating the skyline
so that's the engine
of the arc ship that brought us here and
the whole idea of the colonization plan
was that that was going to be
our nuclear energy source that would
power the city but
then the anomaly hit and that thing
melted down
and it irradiated half the city and you
know those who could escaped into rift
town and those who couldn't the exiles
were trapped out here so this is this is
now home base of the insurgents that
you're moving into you're moving into
their territory now
and okay i guess we're moving on here to
the pyromancer
this is a lot of fire yeah this is
pyromancer all is about the fire and uh
this place is filled with enemies it's
filled with
really dangerous monsters yeah what is
that
yeah i think those things are really
[ __ ] up man
you are not
remember what we said in the beginning
that whatever anomaly touches it changes
yeah those are the creatures that
mutated from the
peaceful creatures now they are not that
there is no cute creatures anymore here
because you are powerful you are almost
good like your skills
but the threat is even more dangerous so
you have to
fight with really really nasty creatures
in your journey oh man all right that's
gonna be fun that's gonna be fun i'm not
like into shooting creatures unless
they're like
really scared so this is this is right
up my alley right here
oh i gotta love the classic tease of the
gigantic boss battle at the end
yeah and that kick-ass gun too yeah yeah
right right and
that gear right there is badass uh is
that kind of the gear that you get
toward the end of the game
oh yeah this is a game that is about
going on a journey to solve an amazing
mystery
and getting some really kick-ass gear no
question about it
the the place you start this game is so
far from where you end up
you go from playing as a human to
something way beyond
you you really you leave humanity behind
yeah
leave humanity behind that's kind of how
i feel sometimes when i watch the news
i'm like totally for that sentiment all
right guys and that about does it for
the outriders reveal
stream the world's press and media
they've already played the game and
right after the stream they are going to
flood the internet with the content of
all their playthroughs so make sure you
check that out
and guys thank you so much for your time
sitting here and chatting with me and i
cannot wait to play the game
i'm pretty sure there's a lot more you
guys are going to reveal between now
and when the game comes out which is
later this year so guys if you want to
know
all the updates that are happening with
this game make sure you check out
outriders.net
and with that guys thanks again for your
time thank you very much
you